Darko I can only imagine how challenging
today was for you personally and
professionally what did you say to the
team before heading up for opening tip
off I told told my guys I loved
him and uh opening play in a game was
atto that um that Dei my friend I
learned that play from him and that's
what he brought to NBA that's what he
brought to Golden State I stole that
play from him and that was our opening
play tonight and we were able to score
on that one
so you know I dedicated this this team
win to our team and and to to
De in the NBA b a bio had 11 points but
20 rebounds on Monday in Brooklyn he
misses his first shot here Scotty B sees
a double Jon Porter finds Gary Trent Jr
and he knocks down the
three as Trent Jr
connects